- All right, let's close
out with something uplifting
I found on the web, this
is "What I'm liking".
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
Summer is almost here in
every part of this country,
there are some activities to try.
Here in California you've got surfing
if you like wetsuits, which I don't.
There are great mountain biking trails
in North Carolina, beautiful actually.
And in Boston, there's rowing
as far as the eye can see
down the Charles River.
So many things.
And one Boston organization is working
to make sure rowing is accessible.
Particularly to kids of all
backgrounds across the city
as well as para-athletes
and military vets.
And this isn't just about exercise,
it's about peace of mind.
To tell us more, let's say
hi to the executive director
of Community Rowing, Inc.,
Ted watching on NBC Boston.
What's up Ted?
(audience applauds)
- So nice to see you, Kelly, thank you.
- Nice to have you on here, man.
So your organization is reaching
a wide variety of people.
So tell us about that.
- Yeah, so a lot of people think rowing
is an elitist East coast activity
reserved just for the few.
And community rowing
serves about 10,000 people
in our community, 85% of whom are youth.
The other 15% are adults obviously.
But we serve 40 public schools in the city
in collaboration with our partner schools.
We go into schools and
bring rowing to kids.
They also come out to our facility.
We also serve veterans
and their families
through free programming.
We go into VA hospitals as
well as bring those folks
back out to our place to
get on the Charles River.
Like you said, we have programs for people
with intellectual and
physical disabilities as well.
Partnership with Children's Hospital
for kids suffering from obesity.
And then we provide affordable
programming and access
for people who wouldn't
otherwise have the background,
experience or ability to
get on the Charles River.
- That's incredible.
(audience applauds)
Most people I would assume,
have not rowed before.
I have, it's so peaceful, I love it.
But most people haven't.
So why do you think this
sport benefits people so much?
- So we've all seen the posters, right?
So you know, the teamwork
posters or the cliches
about putting all your
oars in the water together.
One thing that's special about rowing
is that it's not only
talked about but it's felt.
And with our military vets,
one of the things they say about rowing
is that they experience the
team concept while rowing.
So they're getting a mental connection,
of physical benefits of being together.
But you learn instantly,
whether you're putting the oars
in the water together or not.
And part of the activity is to give people
healthy physical and
safe places to come out
and experience the growth that can come
from something as fun as
being on the river in the city
and the parklands around our city.
- Absolutely.
That connection is so
important, especially
after so many years that
we were, 'cuz of COVID,
everybody was isolated, right?
It's so important.
But also I will say, rowing
alone is therapeutic as well.
Just being out on the
water and it being still,
it takes a lot for some of us with ADHD
to just be still sometimes.
And it's such a beautiful experience.
Thank you so much Ted.
What you're doing is so awesome.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(audience applauds)
- Oh, thank you very much Kelly.
Yeah, that's so wonderful.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- All right, and that's not all.
Our season-long partner
Pilot pen, makers of FriXion,
the go to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate those
helping break down barriers
and open up opportunities
just like you, my man.
So they're gonna give
Community Rowing Inc.
a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience applauds)
- Thank you so much.
- Absolutely, Ted.
Keep doing the work, man, it's working.
Thank you to all our
guests this hour as well.
Garth Brooks, Gwen and Ezri
Y'all have a great day, and if
it's not, try and change it.